hello everyone this game was played in
1890 and I don't know the exact date
this game was played but I do hope it
was 24th of December as this game is
called the night before Christmas and I
think the title fits perfectly as the
nights in this game are really going
crazy I was played between Herman
Clemens and a person named Aizen Schmidt
and I've never really heard of Herman
Clements other than the fact that well
if you start your game with pawn to h3
this is called the Clemens opening but
who does that really and it's it's a
it's really a great game it features the
Evans gambit probably probably my
favorite opening with the white pieces
so I do hope you enjoy it
we have efore by Herman Clements and
Isaac Smith replies with E 5 we have
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to c4
so the Italian game we have Bishop to c5
and we have before the Evans gambit
Bishop capture some b4 c3 Bishop to c5
and d4 well II capture son d4 and well
in the olden days people usually went
for castles here or Queen to b3 to
attack f7 but even though it's 1890
Clemens has a pretty pretty modern
approach to this he please see capture
sandy for creating an eye center and
well kicking the Bishop from c5 we have
Bishop to b6 and the Clemens castles we
have d6 by ice and Schmitt and now
Knight to c3 Bishop to d7 and E 5
Clemens wants to open up this efile
since the black king is still in the
center of the board D captures an e5 and
now not recapturing but playing rook to
e1 trying to open up this efile we have
Knight G to e7 and now Knight to g5 and
in this position
well Eisen Schmitz best hope was the
castle here probably I mean definitely
as well even if he castles there there
really are no tricks for example with
Bishop captures on f7 rook captures on
f7 and Queen to h5 would an attack on
the Rokinon on this h7 pawn as g6 well
solves all of his
problems so after this 95 move probably
best was the castle here but he played
the Bishop to e6 so Clemens played
Bishop captures on e6f captures on e6
and we have Knight captures on e6 what
an attack on this Queen we have a queen
to d6 and our Knight captures on g7 with
Czech and the King to f8 and here we
have a queen to g4 and I mean why not
it's an it's an open bar we have Bishop
captures on d4 pinning this Knight to
the rook and nice to e4 unpinning over
the tempo on the Queen and well even
even better than this nice to e4 move
was actually a knight c6 check as this
was actually completely winning for
white but Clemens missed this he had
Knights the e6 check and after 22 F
seven Knights the e4 now with a tempo on
the Queen and after Queen to d5 simply
Knight captures on c7 and well this
Queen is trapped as there is there's no
square for her I mean you could play
something like Queen to d8 but you have
to keep keep an eye on this ecig square
if the White Queen gets on e6 it's game
over
so if he wants to play something like
for example Queen to d8 you get Quintin
a6 with check and after the King moves
came to a faith this Bishop to h6 is
instant checkmate
but he didn't play this but it's even
better that he didn't because his idea
was even better after this Bishop to d4
he played immediately nights the e4
attacking the Queen we have a Queen to
b4 and now isin Schmidt is threatening
Queen captures anyone with checkmate so
we have 96 with check King to e8 and now
Knight to f6 with check King to f7 and
here Clemens plays the Knight to g5
check he invites Aizen Schmidt to
capture this night on knight on f6 and
let's see what happens if he will if he
was to play this King captures on f6 we
have 26 check we have came to g7 Quinta
f7 check
King to h6 now Knights the e4 check and
there is no way to defend this bishop
check the the black King has nowhere to
go
you would have to play something like
Queen to d2 and after white captures
Bishop to e3 and now this is checkmate
so another very nice idea so after this
Knight g5 move of course either mid
didn't capture the night he played King
to f8 and well white does want to play
this move Queen to e6 the threat and
checkmate on f7 but he can't really do
that because well isin Schmidt is still
threatening Queen to e1 with checkmate
so well there are a lot of moves that
win in this position the simple rook e 2
is completely winning for white but
Clemens finds the most creative solution
to his problems he plays Bishop to a3
and this comes with a temple on the
Queen the queen is now attacked and also
now this a1 rook is protecting the e1
rook so well like it doesn't really have
a good move here he simply captures the
bishop and here we have a queen to e6
now white can play this planets is
threatening Queen to f7 checkmate and
well black plays Knight to DA he's not a
DA to stop the Queen from coming to f7
but the joke is on isin Schmidt as this
is exactly what he gets
Clemens plays Queen to f7 check only
move a knife capture screen and here we
have night tonight's the night the e6
with checkmate and this is what this is
one beautiful night formation this is I
think I really do hope this game was
played on 24th of December as as the
title would really fit a night before
Christmas so yeah that's it for the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Tony more what guitar for a
contribution to my channel you said your
grandparents were also from Croatia and
that maybe we were related well who
knows but you know if you go if you go
far back enough probably all people are
related so yeah that's it as usually you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon